i see how ideas become contagious
in a way i i'm against sort of deifying
any politician
you know these are just people these are
flawed people with whom we sometimes
agree and we sometimes disagree
that's what makes us a great country is
the ability to have dialogue between
opposing ideas and such something out
that makes the most sense for the most
people
very small percentage of each side that
is very very
loud that gives the optics of a war if
you could remove
policy from personal characteristics
what would that be like
all right david pakman man i'm stoked to
have you on the show this is this is a
this is a big deal for me i've been
watching you for a while now
thank you i'm glad to be here so i want
to get a little bit of context because i
know a handful of my listeners won't
really know where you
where you come from what got you into
political commentary what was really the
the
instigation for that move for you i just
started at a community radio station
when i was in college and it was just
sort of the availability it was a brand
new station
and it was just sort of like sign up for
a time slot
sort of situation and i didn't want to
just
play music i didn't want to do sports so
politics was kind of
what was left and you know growing up my
family always talked about politics so i
was super comfortable with it and so it
was kind of the natural direction
man the your family wanting to talk
about politics is
exceptional that's i i start the most
incredible arguments every christmas
every thanksgiving every time i'm around
my family just by bringing in
the idea that maybe socialism is what we
think it is
maybe
yeah there was a time there was a
distinct shift and i think that
smoking weed actually this is why i'm
such an advocate for legalizing
marijuana for
there's a million reasons but for me it
was it was the first moment where i
realized
and i didn't smoke weed till i was in
college i was 20 years old but i'd just
been
flat lied to for years and years and
years
and was like oh this is just this is i
was i succumbed to propaganda
and and this is damaging this is the the
the rhetoric around this substance is
much more damaging than the substance
itself
and that led me down the rabbit hole of
of of questioning everything and coming
from a
small texas town where i was born
straight republican and until proven
otherwise
that was just kind of the options in
christian as well like it would
that started pushing me to the left and
it's been a really interesting
kind of journey to go from kind of far
right listening to rush limbaugh on my
way to work
as a kid to a you know a bernie sanders
supporter it's
been kind of a weird weird dynamic there
yeah that's a big shift
and you know sometimes it goes the other
way as well
you know i've had people call into my
show saying they were raised in super
liberal environments and um sometimes
it's just
because you want to do something
different than what your parents say i
mean
interestingly you know for the most part
people's politics
are often in line with with parents and
the environment that they were raised in
but
also kids sometimes like to go against
what what
their parents beliefs are and sometimes
it's really in terms of religious
beliefs sometimes it's political beliefs
there's all combinations and also
you know over the last eight or eight to
ten years
the impact of being able to get opinions
of of just about any kind online
regardless of whether you're growing up
in you know mississippi or massachusetts
or whatever
that's also changed the picture
absolutely 100
i mean i think this is a time that we
live in here with
so much exposure to information that
there
is a it's a place where we can we can
question
more than i think we could have before
like i mean if you even look at we were
talking about this last night my
girlfriend and i
about the essentially the propaganda
history we learned in schools
and i was kind of educating her on how
you know we brought nazis over
as in in uh operation paperclip and
these things like that that was a really
interesting stories that don't make it
through the filter of
patriotic propaganda and those are fun
things to learn it's it's really
interesting to learn our genuine history
the genuine history of this country
and you have to seek that stuff out but
one thing that's been really amazing is
that it's
there and of course the shadow side of
that is you have you know q anon gets
its claws into things in the same
through the same mechanism
but it's it's been really fun to watch
that play out and
you know something that i came across
you just going down the youtube rabbit
hole probably about a year ago
and you've made this case for joe biden
and i kind of want to i want to circle
around this because i've
as soon as i covet hit i started my
kind of political commentary podcast
which is something that was really
um weighing on me for a while something
i've cared about deeply
and going through the primary and have
having been a bernie sanders supporter
for
since 2015 really it was it was
it was just been such a hard pill for me
to swallow this joe biden
situation like his history his the way
he conducts himself it's just
the disappointment that obama kind of
turned out to be even though the obama
era if i had to compare it to the trump
era was
much better in comparison um
i i'm curious how you made that leap to
being someone who feels that trump is an
existential threat that biden is
is the obvious choice and it's not only
a positive move but it's very necessary
to get him into office yeah well where
to start i mean
listen one of two things is going to
happen on january 20th and that's either
donald trump gets four more years
or joe biden is the next president and
we can go into it in any direction that
you want
whether it comes to you know comparing
things joe biden said in the past
the things donald trump is saying right
now comparing
the platforms of the democratic and
republican party or you know we we can
slice it and dice it however you want
but ultimately these on january 20th
it's one of the two and for me it's very
obvious which is better and the language
of less bad
or better or good and very good or bad
and good
it's sort of irrelevant it's just which
is the preferable
option and for me it's super clear now
what i think has been interesting
is that there are some on the left
who prior to coronavirus
and the george floyd protests we're
pretty strongly
in the i don't like trump but i'm never
voting biden camp
and it's been interesting to see many of
them not all of them
of course but many of them uh take
coronavirus and the last four months
almost like an escape pod
where it allowed them to get out of what
i don't think made sense at the time
which was this never biden ideology
but it gave some people a credible
escape hatch so to speak where they were
able to say okay listen
i was never biden but i never imagined
trump would mess up coronavirus this
badly
i never imagined trump would respond to
protests about police brutality by
sending troops um now
i understand and and it's been
interesting to see that
happen for some on the left not all
certainly
yeah i mean i definitely felt that
within myself i was a very much
i mean i was even kind of running this
leave it blank 2020 type of situation
just because
being in texas it really didn't matter i
mean i guess biden isn't spitting
different distance in texas like he may
make it but i think trump will pull
pull texas um but it was one of those
things where i could kind of have this
protest
non-vote same thing i did with hillary i
just just didn't vote uh in
in the in the presidential election it
was it was it was frustrating as hell
for me to do that
but knowing that texas was going to go
to trump regardless now being in
colorado
i do feel a little bit more of an
obligation to to make a decision
and whether that's voting joe jorgensen
or whether that's voting
biden it's man going in there and just
sighing and gritting my teeth and voting
biden just
it stings sting so bad to have watched
how he became the candidate
like and there's something about
watching watching the democratic party
squirm
brings me joy in the way that they've
conducted themselves over the past 10
years
it's not this isn't something that's new
just the way that it's been exposed how
they've
how they've manipulated the primaries it
hasn't been a fair process the way that
bernie was treated which was completely
unfair
to give to give in to what they want
brings it just
it frustrates me to no end yeah i mean i
think the thing we want to be careful
about is i hear a lot in there
about you and not so much about the
country
and so when i hear you say it
it stings you it makes you cringe or
whatever other words you use
this i i've this is not about me right i
live in massachusetts
massachusetts has if you look at the hdi
human development index
ranking similar to denmark or norway
like
regardless of whether it's biden or
trump
things are going to be pretty okay in
massachusetts and
i'm not suggesting the president doesn't
matter because you know being the
laughing stock of the world
it's bad no matter which state you live
in i i get it
but for me this is not about how do i
feel about bernie's candidacy or
anything else
it's we've lost four years on climate
biden's climate plan
taking from the green new deal would be
the most progressive climate plan of
anybody who's
who's been president period it's to the
left of obama
biden on health care trump's proposals
back in 2017
would have seen 25 to 30 million people
lose health care bidens isn't perfect
but it's to the left of obama's and
about 20 million additional people would
get health care
i have to take myself out of it and i
think that's what's hard for a lot of
people
they want they want biden to come for
their vote
and that's not my perspective i don't
need biden to do anything
for me personally i'm looking at what's
what's better for the country and that's
how i came to my conclusion
that makes a ton of sense and i i feel
you there and
part of me hopes that through this
podcast you convinced me to to pull the
trigger on biden but um
well i mean let me say one other thing
the other thing is i think in this
particular election no matter what state
you're voting in
it it actually matters and the reason it
matters is
it is very likely that uh donald
that that it's going to be close
electorally
and if it's close electorally in
particular if you have what's called the
red mirage scenario the red mirage
scenario is where
because democrats are more likely to
take the virus seriously democrats are
more likely to vote absentee
which means that on election night trump
could
appear to be ahead and have 270
electoral votes but as the absentee
ballots are counted
those leads could evaporate and trump
could end up losing wisconsin he could
end up losing florida
it could be any combination of states
the bigger the popular vote margin
which means people in massachusetts
where biden will obviously win have to
go vote
and people in utah where trump will
obviously win have to go vote because
the bigger the popular vote margin is
the more difficult it will be for any
judge
to give trump anything if indeed we see
lawsuits from the trump administration
or trump campaign to try to stop
accounting of absentee ballots so i
would make the case
that this is not a year to vote third
party and this is not a year to stay
home because your state is very blue or
very red i think everybody's got a vote
no that's
i think i'm really glad you brought that
up that's a very powerful point
you know and i look at these recent
pupils that just came out and and
i was kind of a little surprised about
too surprised and the amount that that
americans distrust media
and i'm curious being being a youtuber
and and having that be your delivery
method for your content
have you have you seen the response to
that shift away from
cnn msnbc i mean you've got you're close
to a million subscribers on youtube now
i know you've been doing this for a long
time i find that i can trust
sources there more than i can msnbc i
mean you flip msnbc cnn fox news i love
to do that little triad
just go back and forth during commercial
breaks and it's
it it's become really disgusting in a
way how they how they've
this trump arrangement says no much
believe me i'm no trump fan
but i think that the the mainstream
criticisms of the man have been
so off base and debunked numerous times
that this the
the distrust of mainstream media in this
country has been
it has been exponentially kind of sped
up
and it's it's weird looking at matt and
i love matt tybee and his book hate inc
it
really showed the light on that and how
trump was elected in the first place was
essentially through distrust of
mainstream media and i'm curious if
there's going to be a time
where they put themselves in some kind
of check
for me and for you it's great because
people are looking for other sources of
news where people can actually talk
straight but i'm curious if you what's
your view on
on the state of media and how people are
getting their news now
well um i think we have to kind of
disaggregate a few different things here
i mean certainly
the corporate media as i call it
uh is is very much influenced by making
money
and that certainly um creates certain
paths that different channels will take
and that's not good and you know i've
talked about that extensively on my
program
trump derangement syndrome i think is a
problematic term um
i i have a couple of stories about this
on my youtube channel but trump
derangement syndrome is
is essentially um a term to
shut down or discredit serious criticism
of the president so i try to stay away
from the term and i encourage people to
stay away from it because basically it's
become
you you make a criticism of trump and
you're you're told you have trump
derangement syndrome that's not an
argument so i i
tend to try to avoid that term when i
hear it i i think we
we probably should explore that a little
bit and then in terms of
you know the narratives about trump have
been debunked i mean i i would just ask
which
which ones and specifically what has
been debunked let's talk about like
russiagate
right that was something that was harked
on continually continuously
for numerous news cycles it never stops
right msnbc has got this thing unlocked
they're talking about all the time
and yes there is russia russia collusion
is likely russia interference is likely
we interfere with elections
all the time as the united states like
that that's a country that has a vested
interest in who
who the leader of that country is
another country is going is going to do
whatever they can
to influence those elections that's just
absolutely that's how it's going
it's been going on for 100 years we do
it to other countries russia does it to
more than just the united states
but i've never seen anybody serious say
that they expected to find evidence of
trump and putin personally colluding i
certainly so
sometimes i'll get calls from people
saying david you were wrong
trump and putin never personally
colluded and i always say
find one instance of me saying that they
did so i think it's important when we
say something was debunked
first we've got to figure out if anybody
was saying it no you're right and i
think it was
the heavy implication without the overt
accusation
you see what i'm saying i do but now
we're now we're in the gray area right
no you're absolutely right that's why
this is why i want you to have me on
have you on the show because a lot of
this stuff comes as a pin as opinion
kind of commentary
and i think you're absolutely right
there is where i'm what i'm talking
about is
was it trump inciting russia to
influence the election or was russia
doing what they thought was best for
russia without trump's influence on
their decision-making
that's right that's that's a beautiful
question yeah i mean i think certainly
russia has identified
that around the world what's good for
russia
especially in western democracy
is anything that reduces trust
in democratic systems so someone like
trump becoming president is
very destabilizing globally the us now
isn't part of a lot of
conversations when global leaders get
together like on climate
that makes the u.s look bad so that's
good for russia so i think that
definitely trump didn't need to ask for
anything right
russia identified they prefer trump so
that does not
involve trump trump did say publicly
russia if you're listening please hack
hillary's emails and then they did
yeah of course now maybe they were going
to do it anyway but so i guess in the
two options you mentioned
it's sort of like a little bit of both
yeah it is a little bit of both and it's
you hear the same criticism coming from
i would say corporate media about
russia wanting a bernie sanders
candidate bernie says bernie sanders
presidency which makes sense it would be
a relatively
doesn't seem as destabilizing but he's a
pro he's an anti-war candidate
and russia doesn't really want us to
start other [ __ ] foreign wars
like it was pretty it made sense that
they would they were they would be happy
with him as
a president so i was like it does it
does it makes sense that any other major
country is going to have a vested
interest in who our leaders are with the
amount of power that we have
and i wish that was i would what i'm
more critical of is i wish that was the
dialogue
right one of the reasons is if with the
with the platform that rachel maddow
house like
looking at what are the reasons that
russia would benefit from a trump
presidency or
a bid like what are the what are the the
implications on that country
versus it's trump's fault trump did it
trump did this trump did that and it's
it it becomes a little bit exhausting
and even if it is true and a lot of the
stuff they say is true
it gets lost in the implications and the
noise is it's kind of my criticism of
the way they're handling the situation
and most people yeah i mean it's it's
also possible that
that's that was your takeaway and not
everybody else's
very possible yeah i'm making this about
me david
[Laughter]
so i'm curious if you think i think if
biden came out and was
very outspoken about legalizing
marijuana and you know more about this
than i do i think the election would be
easily handed to him is there a reason
that you can understand why that's not
that's not a primary part of his
platform so
i think part of the reason why it's not
a primary part of his platform
is that he's not personally for it and
it's just that's what he believes i
think that's part of it i think
it would be complicated for the
democratic nominee
to get ahead of the democratic party on
that issue so i think part of it is
simply politics
but the other thing is that a lot of the
people that would like that
um are in states biden's going to win
anyway and i guess what i would ask
about is i don't know
whether it's that obvious that it would
benefit him overall
i just don't know that's really a
question for a political strategist i
don't know the answer to that it sounds
like you're sort of assuming that
and it may be true i'm just not sure
about that yeah and that's the
i get that from and again i have the
benefit of being from
a very red state in a very small red
town
and when i hear my mom frustrated about
marijuana legalization not being a thing
on anybody's platform
who's a extremely christian you know 50
something
year old woman who's a trump supporter
um
i'm like well that must be that's a
conversation she's having with her
friends
like that that's a conversation in those
in a town where you wouldn't have
thought where i thought when i grew up
that that
was the devil's lettuce type of thing
yeah i mean there's so i was just
looking at new gallup data
and the country is more in favor of
legalization than ever before
so that's true i mean that opinion has
changed
you know calculating the exact impact in
an electoral college system
i i would leave it i would leave it to
someone better better at stats than i am
i totally understand and i do want to
come back to
trump arrangement syndrome because i
love what you had to say there because
that that phrase
and i used it a little bit haphazardly
there has been co-opted by the by the
the right to alt-right whatever
whichever way you want to look at it
and i think what i mean what i mean when
i say that and again making this about
me
is that there's a level there's a
certain type of person that doesn't
understand the appeal of trump
and i think that understanding the
appeal deeply understanding the appeal
of the man gives you a better argument
against him
that's where i feel like as far as as a
strength and kind of proving the case
against trump to
trump supporters which i love getting
into those arguments it's because i come
from a place where
it makes sense that the people that i'm
around that i grew up around my friends
from home essentially
would be trump supporters i deeply
understand
why i don't agree with it by any means
by any stretch of the imagination
but i think there's this there's been
this trend it seems and
correct me if i'm wrong here that
democrats have moved away from the party
of the people into almost making a
character
of of kind of working-class americans
and working-class americans got fed up
with that and slowly
started moving right and then you have a
trump who's
not scared to criticize the media and
say what the [ __ ] he thinks and go on
these down these rabbit holes
and and which i think is completely
deranged and obnoxious
personally but i understand how the how
the
people that i've known my entire life
could resonate with that message as much
as i disagree with it
and i think that's something that that's
missing a lot of times in the in the
left media and i would say that
the far left example of that would be uh
the young turks which i do i do
enjoy their their program from time to
time but it's
the level of condescension coming from
the left to the working class has seemed
to be
a consistent problem so let's see
there's like three or four different
things in there maybe we can take them
one by one i mean first of all the idea
that
that the left has been moving right is
simply not true the country on the
issues is more left than it's ever been
so if we talked about
marijuana the country is more left than
it's ever been
on gun safety even the center now wants
more gun safety laws the country is more
in favor of abortion than it has ever
been
the country is more in favor of the
government providing some basic level of
health
care regardless of whether you can pay
for it or not so i think the idea that
the country has moved right
because of what democrats have done is
is just
untrue on the facts now what is true
is that the narrative the populist um
rhetoric that donald trump employed in
2016
worked on people and i have two or three
different segments on my youtube channel
about how populist rhetoric from the
left
and populist rhetoric from the right
sound very similar
and the difference is implementation and
policy
and so i've talked about not getting
bamboozled by populist sounding rhetoric
because
you know bernie sanders and tucker
carlson can both sound like populists
and then tucker carlson says the
solution is to protect yourself from
black
lives matter taking your house right or
we've got to stop immigration of
hispanic people that's that's the
solution to the populist rhetoric so
i think you're right that the rhetoric
brought some people over to trump
even though the people have not moved
left that's why we've got to be careful
about
you know populist rhetoric in the
absence of actual
policy um i'm trying to think back now
to the third
piece but i i don't remember it offhand
but i think those are some of
my initial reactions yeah i think i was
talking about how the how the democratic
party has kind of made a character of
the
of the working class and they've kind of
shifted into a
[Music]
upper i mean that's what they're doing
now is like is trying to get that
suburban housewife vote
right yeah i mean i think my pushback on
that would be there's just not enough of
those people i mean you just look at
income distribution
and you you don't get remember hillary
got three million more votes than trump
you don't get i don't remember if it was
66 to 63 million or 65 to 62 whatever it
was
if you're just appealing to upper middle
class people you don't get 63 million
votes because there aren't
63 million upper middle class people so
um
i think you know we probably got to
narrow narrow the focus there a little
bit i
i think where i would criticize the
democratic party
is that they've only been slightly to
the left of republicans on a bunch of
issues
where i would rather than rather see
them more to the left the way you see
in some european countries you have real
you know more left parties
i think that would be a fair criticism
um
but yeah i mean mathematically the idea
that the middle class has abandoned the
democratic party
it's not it's a mathematical
impossibility based on 60 something
million votes last time around oh you're
you're absolutely right and and i think
one thing that
i'm really enjoying about this is i'm
i'm throwing you the narratives that i
hear all the time
and i appreciate that you're able to to
clap back on those in a way
and looking at this i'm curious
i had this actually this really fun
conversation i was hunting
two days ago with some buddies right so
we're all out with guns
we're all i mean one guy came from san
francisco i came from texas like i've
been around guns since i was old enough
to hold them
i understand gun culture and we all sat
there and had our fair criticisms
of gun laws and the way that they're
they don't make any sense they're
extremely convoluted there need to be
better gun policies
and all of us sitting there holding
firearms
like it was it was really fun for me to
see how
people who on the right on the left kind
of across the political spectrum
for guys sitting around hunting
saying the gun law issue or the gun gun
gun
uh regulations are a freaking problem
like this
it was it was something really intense
for me to see that it wasn't just me
because i
mean me being you know pro second
amendment and understanding there's a
there's
a million ways that we could make this
safer
and better for everybody if the nra
didn't get involved and
they weren't so powerful and if the
right wasn't didn't have their heels dug
in
on making pragmatic changes it makes no
sense it makes absolutely no sense i
bought an ar-15 at 18 years old which
you shouldn't be able to do
and i sold it to a guy 10 years later
in a costco parking lot in texas and
everything i did was legal now i knew
the guy it was safe the guy's former
military it wasn't his only weapon
like that that he had owned it was it
wasn't anything sketchy but
even in the in the act of doing it i was
like this is this is this is absurd
this should not be okay why why can't i
do this and it no one bats an eye and no
one thinks twice about it it's it's a
it's a very interesting topic that i
think some people from the left
don't have an understanding of what i
call gun culture where you are literally
shooting i started shooting
real guns at five years old like it is
just a part of the life that i had
growing up and i don't really do it as
much anymore
but the people that i grow up grew up
around
that's a huge part of their life and to
threaten that is to
one lose their vote and to not offer any
pragmatic solutions and i think that
from what i've seen of joe biden's gun
policy
it doesn't make a ton of sense and what
i saw was him taxing
essentially taxing extended magazines
attacked
attacks on you know high-capacity
firearms some automatic firearms
similar to assault rifle assault style
weapons that didn't really
it didn't really click with me as
something that would be effective it
just seemed like something that would
piss a lot of people off
yeah i mean i think there's a huge
conversation to have about firearms
in terms of this election to be honest
i've not even looked at joe biden's
policy on guns because it ranks so low
among voters as to what matters it's
like number one right now is coronavirus
number two is economy number three is
racial unrest
and i've said on my program that
i i have a hard time remembering an
election in which
gun rights mattered less now donald
trump has been trying to make it a thing
by saying joe biden will end the second
amendment which
it's hard to imagine a more idiotic
comment joe biden doesn't have the power
to eliminate the second amendment the
second amendment is here
and there's not going to be another
amendment passed to undo the second
amendment under joe biden
um but you know i've general thoughts
on this issue but in this particular
election it does not seem like it is
going to rank as an issue that affects
the outcome
no you're you're absolutely right and it
is it's really just if you think back to
the the
the bush era like this was a humongous
issue
it was it was one of the keystone issues
of the election so as far as coronavirus
response goes
and i want to kind of if we can
speculate a little bit looking forward
how does that shift in a joe biden
administration like what
what really changes and how does it
change for the better going with it with
a joe biden administration
well i think a lot of it is going to
depend remember january what's the
situation
in january on the ground um
we likely will start to have vaccine
distribution at that point in time
and we will be starting to get to the
other side of the flu season
so i think it a lot of the things that
went wrong
already went wrong and at this point
we're in the phase of trying to mitigate
um mitigate death until we have
treatments
and vaccines so i think that's a
difficult question to answer
i think if in january the situation is
so bad
that we need some kind of national mass
mandate joe biden
has said he would do it you know will
people adhere to it
i don't know at that point
what will be the situation in terms of
schools you know the debate about
schools is for right now
by the spring semester we may have a
very different situation
um so unfortunately you know when you
look at us now approaching 200 000
deaths a lot of the damage has already
done
and then the next step hopefully is
going to be
that medical science is going to start
cleaning up the mess of course being
unable to get back the 200 000 people
that have died now at the same time
the the ihme model says the death toll
could be 400 000 by january
and if that's the case and we're back up
to 70 80 000 cases a day
we're just going to have to see what the
situation is at the time but really the
mistakes that were made
are in the past and um
you know they continue to be made donald
trump is not participating in the global
effort
to obtain and distribute vaccines he's
sort of doing it
the the go it are by ourselves approach
that failed when it came to testing it
was
a disastrous decision on testing um
so there's going to be a lot of wait and
see
what's going on in january yeah and this
is going to be this is the
it's a weird time that we're living
through and i want i've heard you bring
this narrative up on your show and this
is
i've set in this and i've thought about
this a lot
i've seen over the last four years right
i think hillary clinton was an atrocious
candidate
i that was the way that that went about
was absurd
the prediction that donald trump i had a
feeling he was going to win a month
beforehand
even though the polling showed something
completely different biden is much more
likeable
biden is much a much more likable almost
like a granddad type figure and there
that does play a role
in this election but what i've seen over
the last four years is an intense
mobilization of young people
specifically and people that are dis
enchanted by our political system that
are speaking up
and becoming more active in a
response to trump there's nothing he did
intentionally it's actually in
an opposition to him is there
is there any logic in thinking that four
more years of trump
will pl will pay dividends down the road
as far as the number of people that are
pushed more in alignment with your
politics and my politics in opposition
to
having to deal with a clown as president
for eight years
no i don't think so i think that um so
that that would fall under more of an
accelerationist paradigm where sort of
like the worse things get
the more people get activated to change
those things
and in some general sense
it's possible that that that's true
but the reality is that if you look at
like the big moments in history where
progressive change happened which would
be
the progressive era from like 1890 to
1920
um the post-world war ii era the new
deal
era for fdr um and the civil rights era
that started in the late 50s and lasted
through until you know mid to late 60s
depending on how you want to couch it
that was all incremental change that
improved on what came before it
a lot of it depended on supreme court
justices
reminding us of the importance of if you
have trump for four years picking
supreme court justices
he's going to do less damage than if
he's in there for eight years picking
supreme court justices so
no i don't i don't think so um i think
that
putting a stop to this and starting to
write
some of the wrongs starting to
rehabilitate our image and relationships
around the world
i think that that is what will be better
in the short term and what will be
better in the medium term and what will
be better in the long term
all right i respect that yeah and that's
it's it's it's a slippery thought and it
does
it puts me in a place of thinking i mean
it's it's
it almost seems like it's um a little
bit of a fairy tale that i like to tell
myself
well i don't it's not so much a fairy
tale i mean a lot of it is
um it's it's the idea
that um if things get really bad
the opportunity to rebuild it in our
image will be simpler or more
straightforward but i think what
sometimes people underestimate there
is if things get that bad through no
fault of our own because of something
external we just deal with it the best
we can
but to welcome it is almost
irresponsible in a sense because
for things to really get so bad that
we're rebuilding the foundations of
society
you're talking about untold death and
destruction both economic and physical
and so even if you were to get to it it
could be at the cost
of who knows what number of lives and to
me it seems almost irresponsible to
welcome that
yeah that makes sense makes a lot of
sense so
speaking of untold numbers of lives um
healthcare
biden's healthcare plan how
i mean draw draw a difference here what
what's the primary
key point differences between a biden
administration health care initiative
and the next four years of trump as far
as health care goes this is super
important to a lot of people
i mean especially coming out of a covet
situation where
i mean not to mention credit card debt
and things like that are going to be out
of control
because people lost their incomes it's
it's been wild this is this is a this is
an unprecedented time this is this is
insane it's it feels it feels uh if
steel
doesn't feel real it feels like we're in
some kind of simulation where this is
just like
the boss battle or something this is it
makes still
i can't wrap my mind around it to the
level that it's impacting
the lives of people all across this
country what are
the advantages of abide in health care
initiative versus what trump has
i mean and taking his word for it is is
a hard thing to do
but going forward where where are the
key differences
well we don't know what trump would do
on health care over the next four years
so what we do know is during the
campaign trump said that during his
first year in office he would replace
obamacare
um that that didn't happen obviously
obviously
the two proposals that republicans put
out
would have led to depending on which
estimate you look at
24 to 32 million people losing health
care coverage through a combination of
it becoming less affordable
reducing access adding ways for health
insurance companies to kick people off
etcetera
now a few month and a half ago donald
trump said that within two weeks he
would be signing a new health care bill
into law
it didn't say what was in it didn't
happen anyway
so i think the problem with comparing to
what we would see under trump is we have
no idea it would probably be nothing
like the ideas have so far been so bad
that he probably would get nothing done
yeah but if he got the things done that
he's tried so far
it would be very very bad 25 32 million
people would lose health coverage
what joe biden wants to do is to start
with obamacare as the framework
um and at a public option
that's expected to pull down premium
prices
uh industry-wide a little bit and in
total
uh i i'm trying to remember the numbers
it's if you add up all these different
things somewhere around 25 or 30 million
more people will get coverage
part of it would be through additional
subsidies part of it would be
because the public option will be
cheaper and people will be able to
afford it
biden has talked about being in favor of
lowering the medicare age from 65
to 60. or might have even been 55 so you
know you add up all of this stuff and
about 30 million more people will get
health care it's not bernie's plan but
if you say
david listen the two options are 30
million people lose health care or 30
million people gain health care that's a
delta of 60 million i know which one i'm
going with right
yeah absolutely and is there a place for
caution or criticism in the in the
amount of influence that the health
insurance
and pharmaceutical companies have on
policy and law making
of course absolutely yeah i mean listen
um
we some countries don't have for-profit
health insurance
health insurance companies are
non-profits they're run almost like a
public utility in some sense
um so of course yeah and that applies no
matter who's president
yeah yeah and that's i feel what a
libertarian would say and i've had
libertarians on this show
is that that would stifle innovation
that one of the greatest things about
having a for-profit healthcare
system is that we are more innovative
than other countries is there any
real truth to that or is that something
that's just another
fantasy that's fun to believe well much
like with a lot of these
libertarian fantasies it's everything is
shades of grey right yes so it is
true that uh there are aspects of how
things are organized here that lead to
innovation as it's called at the same
time there are countries that are
organized in other ways that have also
had
innovations i mean you look at china you
look at cuba you look at russia those
are countries that are organized in
other ways
they have the power of the government
deciding hey
we're doing this thing and then they go
and they do it now
i'm not a socialist i'm not a communist
i'm not advocating for those systems i'm
merely pointing out that these black
white
ideas often fall very short but i think
the more interesting
conversation is if in the end
the innovation is happening at a
for-profit company it's happening
because of government which is there
to establish intellectual property law
and enforce it it's there because of the
u.s
postal service and public schools which
a whole bunch of the employees who are
doing the innovation went to i mean you
know it's
this is why we call them libertarian
fantasies because
they ignore that okay cool jeff bezos
did
x but he did it with 50 000
employees educated in public school
mailing stuff around with the us postal
service
with contract law enforced by the
judiciary i mean you know it's
like i love that take that's hilarious
now the libertarian libertarianism is a
really it's a fun
rabbit hole to go down and it is really
interesting but it seems
almost like it would work in oklahoma if
oklahoma was a sovereign country
with however many you know 30 million
people maybe it
has legs but at scale it just does not
it just does not hold water in at the
level
i don't even know that it has legs and
it's i mean it's like
you what what you basically end up with
is
instead of government and and sort of
consensus being the governing body
you have whoever gets the most guns the
quickest and
i don't know that that's better right i
just don't know that that we're actually
better off if that's the case
and you know the reality is that there
are certain things that are too big for
anybody but government to regulate
effectively the idea that well
this town is is regulated in this way
and this town is regulated this other
way because these people had the ar-15s
and nobody else did and eventually
that's sort of like what it comes down
to
um there are certain things like
multi-billion dollar corporations
really only government can effectively
regulate them across a country or across
the world that's the reality of the
globalized
planet we live on yeah that makes it
makes a ton of sense and it's
it's it's challenging it's a challenging
thing sometimes
to argue but it seems like yes we have a
ton of flaws and i think that
i'm not a hardcore capitalist or a
socialist i think that the idea that
it's that black and white is is a lie
it's just a lie we've been sold
right like socialist programs make a ton
of sense they add a tremendous amount of
value to this country make the country
as great as it is
um and i think a lot of capitalist
values make a ton of sense as well but
there's
there's a place where regulation is
essential
it's essential and the things like
amazon and jeff bezos like those are
people being paid with their paid like
there's no one they can look at that and
think about an employee taking a piss in
a bottle
on the on the floor because they can't
you know essentially amazon is a
logistics company and they can't take a
five-minute break
to go do what they need to do when if
you're you know
well educated and you have the privilege
to make that happen you essentially end
up working a four hour or five dollar
work day
maybe and you can do it yeah yeah
no one sees that doesn't think it's
disgusting in some way right
well some people do there are
libertarians who say uh
if that is what the market is offering
and people don't like it
then they should either go and look for
a different job which will
raise the wage that needs to be paid or
it'll force amazon to allow five-minute
breaks or whatever
that there are libertarians who actually
would defend that but it's
you know it's it's it's sort of a
fantasy world i think more relevant
is um you know my view is a sort of
northern european
socially democratic view which is we
want markets
and we want private industry and
i am very comfortable with markets and
profit
directing the activity of many types of
companies i don't need the government
making all of the mobile phones i think
it's fine that you know
apple can make a phone and samsung and
lg and
i'm fine directing resources um in that
way
but there are certain things that should
be taken out of that mechanism
healthcare would be one of them
education would be one of them
you know i think the postal service is a
great service that i'm perfectly fine
with it not being profitable that's sort
of my
perspective which is i'm okay with
markets directing resource allocation
except when it really doesn't make sense
and we should figure out a different
system
and the idea that that that that
regulation
uh kneecaps that that industry or that
market
is incredibly naive to me i think that
those that markets are so powerful and
so robust that
regulation is is necessary in
like minimum wage in this is another
libertarian fantasy that minimum wage is
a
is a violation of our rights or
something it it
that's necessary because the funny thing
is that
this is what trusts me out about
libertarians they love that like
competition is the is the bedrock of
their whole thing if you have if you
have free markets and you have
competition in competition
runs essentially their whole system it
is the check and balance within the with
that system
yeah it's usually it's that and the this
sort of like non-aggression principle
that they
that they cite exactly but companies
don't want to compete
so as soon as they can purchase
influence and minimize competition
they're going to do that
it's in it's in the nature of an of an
industry to not want to compete
it's in the nature of a human being to
not want to compete if you don't have to
compete
so so it's it's against the nature of an
industry
to follow the rules of libertarianism
that's one thing that i've never really
been able to wrap my head around is how
can you not see that very glaring
gap in your logic yeah it certainly
concentrates and creates
monopolistic uh industries and and uh
circumstances that that's
very much true um but again sort of
going back to what we said earlier the
other area where it fails is once some
of these entities get so big
there really isn't anything but the
power of government to do
the regulation yeah and i think that
i'm curious what your thoughts are on
this i it feels that
campaign finance reform is the most
necessary thing
that we can change like the amount of
influence that industry has on policy
making
to me is on its face just completely
unfair
and i don't know i haven't seen anybody
run on that outside of maybe a
libertarian candidate here or there i
think bernie talked about it in 2016
more than 2020
is there is there any is that does that
make sense at the end of the day does
that make sense that campaign finance
reform
would make a profound shift in
everything from health care to industry
and regulation
yeah i mean i think really like the
three pillars
that like if you care about education
versus if you care about gun rights
versus if you care whatever issue you
care about
really what we need to be looking at is
campaign finance reform
changing the first-past-the-post voting
system to better enable
third parties to participate and uh
number three
dealing with climate change because if a
city is under water it's hard for its
residents to be advocating for anything
so that
if you said what are the kind of like
the top three things that
across all political issues need to be
dealt with i would say it's those three
yeah absolutely and and i would say also
four is healthcare because
if you're sick and you can't access
healthcare you also can't be an activist
for education or gun rights or whatever
you want so probably those are the four
oh man that brings to mind that ben
shapiro clip where he told he said that
if
people's houses were underwater they
could just sell them
i did not see that it was incredible it
was incredible
i love when that guy puts his foot in
his mouth he cracks me up so
going forward i mean you've you've have
you you've seen this shift in people
towards a never biden to swallowing the
hard pill to swallow
and biden what are your predictions as
far as the debates go because the did
you i i've got to bring this up with you
the dude's cognition
just does not seem on point you're
talking about trump
i'm talking about well trump's isn't
either but biden's oh but i would say if
trump is at a seven as far as his
cognition being messed up biden's
probably at an eight or a nine
oh um yeah i don't know about that i
mean so he i guess here's my thought
when the democratic primary got down to
just biden and bernie you had all sorts
of people saying
oh no joe biden he's not going to be
able to get a sentence out he's going to
get crushed
he can't speak he doesn't know where he
is and biden did fine and then won the
primary by millions of votes
and so i think that there's no doubt
that joe biden in 2020 is not joe biden
from 2012 who ran circles around
paul ryan in the vp debate that's true
um but i think any expectation that
biden is going to fall apart i mean
listen the last 10 days
he's been doing more public events as
it's been able to be done safely
he's taken questions from reporters he's
fired back at trump
um i don't expect much from the debates
uh one way or the other
i think it's going to be in particular
this year more people will have voted
already by the time the last debate even
happens which i think is like october
22nd or something like that
so i don't unless someone makes a really
big mistake i don't anticipate the
debates making much of a difference
i was i was a little bit proud of biden
i think he only had one gaffe in that
hole in the last like three or four
appearances
so it was it wasn't that it wasn't one
of his worst ones by any means
yeah and i mean listen trump uh is
constantly mispronouncing words things
are flying out of his mouth at a press
briefing yesterday it wasn't clear
whether it was
uh you know spit mucus or adderall that
was flying out of his mouth
he's sweating he's melting he's bright
red he's talking about
minneapolis he pronounces anarchist
anarchists
and uh i think you know
i i would be more skeptical of the guy
constantly bragging about how well he
did on a dementia test
than the guy who's just campaigning well
that's the thing is is
uh trump gets his words out more
effectively but it doesn't do him any
favors
almost rather him have a little bit of a
slowdown just to just to just
calm like think about what you're saying
before you put it out in the world man
come on
and that's i i don't have a huge issue
with his
ability to get words out because you can
tell they're there
if he was having a conversation that was
important with somebody that could give
him a little time to get it out i don't
think it would be an issue
but it's i mean is the 70 hell is he 76
which one biden is
77 maybe and i think trump's 74
73 yeah which i think both are a little
bit too old to be doing what they're
doing but
that is where we're at but i think that
having a 76 year old man on a stage with
eight other people
and in front of a crowd yeah the guy's
gonna have a hard time getting things
together
but when he get when it came down to him
and bernie like he did do an excellent
job
and of course yeah yeah i i i'm not
really worried about the debates for me
it's more a question of
uh do they do they even matter in this
particular case i don't
i don't think so unless biden just
completely puts his foot in his mouth
yeah yeah i mean and and it's likely
trump will but i don't think it will
matter because trump's
trump's base is very committed to him
man and i loved it it brought me so much
joy i was actually out in the mountains
for about four days
and i came back and the first thing i
saw on uh just popped up my phone was
that boats were sinking in lake travis
which is where i grew up i lived in
austin for 10 years at lake travis
that was crack seeing those people
freaking out with their with
just both sinking full of trump trump
flags
so many flags by the way i mean i drive
it's so funny when you get outside of
denver
it turns into which is where i'm at now
it turns into trump country and people
have
full-on billboards built in their front
yards that say god bless america god
bless donald trump
like and it's um the amount of
excitement these people have and the
commitment that they have to this figure
this
superhero in their mind
i guess i can't wrap my mind around you
being that excited about any political
figure
ever i don't unders i don't understand
it and obama got people excited
obama got people really excited i mean i
didn't vote for obama but i saw him
speak at my college and i was i was very
moved of course i still had my
conservative conservative roots that led
me a different direction but
i look going back now knowing what i
know i probably would have made a
different decision
but 20 year old me just didn't have the
wherewithal to make that happen but
the amount of excitement that people
have and the commitment that they have
to this man to donald trump
regardless of what he does what he says
it's
it's this level of confirmation bias at
scale that i've
never seen before well it's very
cult-like i interviewed stephen hassan
who's an expert on cult and cult
behavior
and a lot of what's going on is very
cult-like and when trump says you know
he could shoot people on fifth avenue
and wouldn't lose any support
it that very well may be true and it is
it is a sign of a cult
and i i've warned my audience generally
that i i'm against sort of deifying any
politician
and we saw with barack obama i didn't
really see
the deification of barack obama i saw
excitement
and it was because barack obama brought
an idea of what a politician or a
president could be to the table now
whether he met
that ideal is a different question but
he he excited people in a way
that i didn't find to be very cult-like
but
trump has cult-like followers around him
i was worried
during the primary that bernie sanders
tulsi gabbard and andrew yang had some
cult like elements
around their followers and what i've
always and it doesn't mean they didn't
have good ideas of course
i always say you know these are just
people these are flawed people with whom
we sometimes agree and we sometimes
disagree
um and they also tend to be slightly
narcissistic people
people who tend to go into politics on
average or a little more narcissistic
than the average person
and so for me it's what can they do for
the country
rather than um getting behind them as
people
and allowing the sort of cult like stuff
to build i don't think that's
particularly
good for no matter who the candidate is
so think about like
with a with a yang or a tulsi gabbard or
a bernie type
cult what's the what's the downside of
that
well the downside is you become blinded
to the realities
and you simply say this this is the
person and it's about the person rather
than
their ideology and i don't think that's
particularly good because really when
we're talking about elected officials
it's kind of like the combination of
their policy positions and what they're
going to do
and when it becomes about the person i
don't know that it's beneficial to
anybody
yeah i think that's a really profound
shift and matt tybee does talk about
that at length how it became
the narrative i don't know what year
this was but it was whenever it was it
was which candidate would you like to
have a beer with
and it's like well the person you would
rather have a beer with might not be the
best
president like that just because he
would like him as your neighbor doesn't
mean that they would
you know be the best leader of the
country yeah that's a fair point it's a
very interesting dynamic that we've seen
and it's it's definitely put a lot of
really
astute politicians in a bad position
because they're just not personable and
they're not charismatic
but you look at the most charismatic
people we've had in office i mean look
at reagan like what
what his impact was we're still dealing
with his busted ass economic policies
today yeah if anything you know
there's these ideas sometimes people
float about
you we would be voting for candidates
without knowing who they were we
wouldn't know whether they're male or
female we wouldn't know their race we
wouldn't know their age
you would just vote based on a written
policy platform
and of course this would never happen
but the idea is that if you could remove
policy from personal characteristics
what would that be like and i think it's
an interesting question to think about
the reality is you are also voting based
on
the personal experience of the
individual you are also voting on their
their age to a certain degree
that stuff does also matter when you're
picking a leader but it's an interesting
thought experiment
absolutely absolutely and i look look
get into this and it's
it's interesting to see how many ideas
that we've had brought up like in like a
universal basic income which are have
become in the last
year mainstream ideas and
hearing people discuss that gives me a
lot of hope because i think
i see how ideas become contagious
in a way and they build a little bit of
steam and they get it's almost like
they're in this
incubation period of getting bounced
around and finding the best way and
becoming a part of a cultural
norm and looking at this and i kind of
take a human behavior science lens went
through to politics right so it's less
about the policy and more about the kind
of cult of understanding and how things
develop
looking at this and seeing these the
shift away
from i mean for our generation at least
this cold war mentality against like the
red scare type of stuff and knowing that
looking back that that may have not even
even even been what we were told it was
and
looking at something like universal
basic income and how how automation is
going to change the landscape that we
live in
uh particularly for for uneducated jobs
right like truck driving in 20 years is
not going to really be a career that you
can
that you can have it's just not a thing
unless you're sitting in an automated
truck just making sure everything goes
well
and and knowing having people on a
debate stage in a primary like andrew
yang bringing those ideas up i feel is
incredibly powerful
just to giving us a little bit more
context on what else could be
in in developing this country into what
it will become and we're almost the
cultural war
seems very real right now but it seems
like those ideas
are going to give us a little bit more
stability later on even though now it's
it's kind of dissolved us into chaos it
seems
well i mean i think andrew yang's
presence in the primary was great i
interviewed him three times and i
thought he brought a lot of interesting
ideas forward
i think you know the critique of andrew
yang is maybe because of his business
background he saw everything as a
consulting project
and less about some of the political
realities that include coalition
building and
diplomacy and a lot of other things but
it didn't i mean
he never pulled more than two percent so
it really for me not to be rude but it
was about what ideas is he introducing
into the debate and i think that was a
really great thing
yeah um in terms of the culture war you
know i think that that's also a fraught
term
not as fraught as trump derangement
syndrome but i think it can it can
sometimes be a fraught term
in the sense that sometimes there are
there are cynical actors who will call
something a culture war
because they believe that calling it
that benefits their side when really
it's not much of a cultural war it's the
fact that it's a country of 331 million
people
and it's huge and different people have
different ideas
it doesn't mean it's a cultural war and
i think it's important to really look
specifically at a lot of those issues
you know abortion is abortion a culture
war well for years it's been a really
great way for the for the right to raise
money that's true
but it's been a losing war for one side
in the sense that
every time people are surveyed the
country is
more in favor of abortion being legal so
it's not so much a war
because it's not setting the battle
lines of debate in any real sense
anymore so i think we want to look at
those issues with
a careful eye when i think in the way i
look at this quote-unquote culture war
is
the very small percentage of each side
that is very very
loud that gives the optics of a war
that's right
that's right and i think that's why it's
important not to think there is really a
war when there isn't
yeah when you when you sit down with
someone who's left-leaning and someone
who's right-leaning if they were a venn
diagram they'd be mostly
crossed over in gray well that's
interesting i mean that
that's a that's a mechanism of
a democratic party that's not very far
left
that puts a lot of what our elected
officials agree on in the same circle in
the venn diagram that that's very much
true now that doesn't mean that the
differences aren't important
they are and they're really different on
a lot of issues but you
you are you are right about that you
know there's a lot of the status quo
stuff like
you know the the general gist of the
budget and military spending where
they're arguing around the edges but
democrats and republicans in the senate
are all mostly
pretty close on that issue and i think
it's important to point that out
yeah it is and i think i think some of
the most problematic areas of our
government are the ones where they align
right they kind of can they can dangle
out the differences and the differences
again are very important
but when it comes to defense spending
and how we're conducting ourselves in
foreign countries
it's that they seem to be pretty aligned
on that and they seem to be taking a lot
of the same money from the same people
in the same organizations yeah and when
you look at industries
the big industry you know you look at
healthcare you look at defense you look
at
um telecommunications you know the cable
companies that that have
virtu near monopolies in most places
they're mostly donating to both sides is
the truth
i mean they're playing yeah they're
playing both sides that makes the most
sense
yeah it's capitalism after all
so man david this has been super super
informative and really fun and i
appreciate you
being able to one of the reasons i'm
really glad to have you on is because i
needed to get
a little bit of a check as far as could
you get down the rabbit hole man
confirmation bias is a strong
part of human nature and i'm not immune
to i'm not immune to being manipulated
as well and i think that
voices like yours out in the world
and and i do love as much as youtube
censorship has gotten a little bit out
of hand i love that
it's a platform for people like you to
create an audience that you've that
you've put together man
and is there anything before we get out
of here that you really want to bring up
or let anybody know
uh before we wrap it up i would just say
uh if
if you're thinking of voting definitely
do it this is this is the year to do it
that's that's really my only message
absolutely man and i think you may have
uh i think you may have swayed me if
that that makes any difference at all
but i'm have to eat a little bit of crow
because i was i was uh i was
very vocal about my um disdain for joe
biden
many were many were listen uh there's
nothing to be ashamed about it's
all about we we should welcome people
revising their views when they have new
information i think that's a great thing
yeah i absolutely believe that and i
think that that's something that we can
all take a a lesson from is that just
i think disagreement is important and i
think looking forward into the
government
having an actual left and an actual
right is a very beneficial thing for us
you know i think i think the right does
that a little bit better than the left
does as far as accepting
uh like libertarians right which is a
far a far right kind of
idea like they have a rand paul speaking
that out and we do have aoc and we do
have bernie in there as well so that we
have a little bit of that but i think
that having an actual left an actual
right and that that debate and that
dialogue between the two
as opposed to a center-left democratic
party in a very right
republican party gives us more balance
and more opportunities as a country i
mean i think that makes us
that makes this place what it is and
that that's that's what makes us a great
country is the
ability to have dialogue between
opposing ideas and sus something out
that makes the most sense for the most
people
i agree and the only thing i would add
is when some of the ideas are completely
whacked out crazy at some point
do you draw a line and say these ideas
don't even really deserve a seat at the
table
i think you do and you know where the
line is is probably
a conversation for a different day yeah
i think but i think a few of the people
that have on the other side of that line
are going to be elected to congress
um that may be yeah so that'll be
that's good i'm it'll be good for
content but i don't know if it'll be
good for the country
that's exactly right well david uh we
can find you on youtube at the david
pakman show anywhere else that you
people can find you at
yeah just my website davidpakman.com
right on man i'll link to all those in
the show notes and uh we'll have to do
this again sometime
thanks so much for having me